O kim
ve bütün dönemler boyunca sorunlarla ve
mücadelelerle
karşılaşmış ve sorunları mücadeleri
çözme yolunda çalışmalar yapmış
insanoğlunun ilk sorunu barınma ymış
barınma sorunu yaşamış bunun için
kendine Barınaklar yapmış mağaralar
yapmış ve mağaraların bünyesinde
yaşamaya çalışmış yemeğe ihtiyaç olmuş
yeme ihtiyaç olduğu zamanda avcılık
yapmış daha sonra bakmış Toprak var
meyve ve sebze üretmeye başlamış ürünler
elde etmeye başlamış
elde ettiği ürünlerin sonunda görmüş ki
İnsanoğlu bunu hem tarımda hem
hayvancılıkta
ve elde ettiği ürünleri artık
başkalarına
verebilir başkalarıyla paylaşabilir
duruma geldiğini görmüş ve Ticaret
başlamış
ticarette metalar devreye girdiği için
altın para değerli madenler gün yüzüne
çıkmış ve bunlar kullanılmaya başlanmış
bunların tamamında İnsanoğlu bir takım
mücadele içerisinde gitmiş bu mücadele
Aslında yeni bilgi veri ve bu bilgi ve
veri ile elde edilen kazanımlarla
mücadelenin karşılığını bir problemi
çözdük görmüş
bunun akabinde
Tabii şehirleşme başlamış
ve diğer insanlarla bir araya gelmişler
onlarla münasebete girmişler aradığında
Bilişim başlamış
tekerlekten sanayileşmeye kadar
tekerleği bulmaktan sanayinin ötesinde
dijitalleşmeye kadar bütün süreçlerde
hep Biriyle beraber yaşadı veriyi bir
bilgi hep yakındık
Ben bunu bir piramit olarak düşünürsek
insanoğlunun ilk basamaklarından ilk
yaşama Savaşı'ndan bugüne kadar olan tüm
süreci bakacak olursak şu anda piramidin
en tepesinde verilebildiği var veri ve
bilgi şu an hayatımızın odağında günümüz
teknolojilerinin öznesi olmuş durumda
Bizler veri ve bilgiyi insanoğlu olarak
doğru bir şekilde kullanmamız gerekiyor
ve beri bir bilginin vermiş olduğu
bilimsel tabanı da hayatımızı yansıtarak
hem bulur hem yenilik hem de hayatımızı
göndermemiz gerekiyor sadece
insanoğlunda mı sorun var o mu Sadece
problem yaşıyor hayatında Hayır
bu hayvanlar bitkiler canlı ve cansız
bütün varlıklar biriyle konuşuyor
arkadaşlar hepsi birbiriyle konuşur
hepsinde bilgi transferi var
birbirlerini bir bilgi transferi da
çünkü yaşamak istiyorlar
bakınız bir orman yangını düşünün
hepimiz çok üzülüyoruz
orman yangını yaşadığımız zaman
ağaçların üzerinde Yani para böyle
gördüğümüz yerde gördüğünüz kozalaklar
vardır ya o kozalakları bir tekme atarız
alırız kapımıza Böyle bir taç yaparız
süsleriz başımıza Taç yaparız çocukları
arasında boya oyunlar oynanır okozalak
çok önemli bir kozalak Esasen
yangın orman yangını çıktı zaman yanan
ağaçla beraber okul olarak açılıyor
arkadaşlar yavaş yavaş okul açılır
içerisindeki polen ortaya çıkar ve
yangının Vermiş olduğum bu beraber doğru
havaya çıkar
bu yükselir yükselir yükselir yükselir
ve o hava basıncı o Rüzgar o poleni alır
kendisine en uygun olan coğrafi indirir
ve orada o bilgiyi tekrar yaşatacak
tekrar kazandıracak yeni bir fidan olur
hayatına tekrar devam eder
ve o kozalağın o kadar büyük bir önem
var hayatımızda da hor gördüğümüz
kozadan O da bilgi taşıyor O da bir
taşıyor O da canlı O da yaşamına devam
etmek istiyor bakınız Kelebekler birisi
de bir belgesel izledim evde Ağzım açık
kaldı öyle bir çekmişler ki inanamadım
ya gel Gerçekten mükemmel bir çekim iki
kere bebeğin hayatını anlatmış Paris'te
işte bir tanesi şanzelizede bir tanesi
notrdam da Kelebekler iki ay biri erkek
biri dişi kelebek Akşam karanlık oluyor
Akşam karanlıkta ya erkek olan kelebek
dişi olan kelebi ulaşmak istiyor Çünkü
amaçları çiftleşmek birbirlerine bilgi
vermek ve
kelime yolculuğu izliyoruz 20 kilometre
karanlıkta
ve bütün etki faktörlerini düşünün ışık
lamba kokular ağaçlar şunlar bunlar
birsürü farklılık etken madde var ve o
etken maddelerin arasında kelebek uçuyor
İskele bi buluyor onun göndermiş olduğu
sinyallerle kimyasallarla bir o
kelebekle
birleşiyor ve akabinde ölüyor
Bütün canlılar birbirlerine muhtaçlar
Bütün canlılar verilebildiği üzerine
kurulmuştur da benim hayatım bunun
üzerine Tolga kaskatı
3996 yılında ilk defa üniversiteye
girdim
Allah Allah razı olsun babamı sayesinde
girdim Annem ve babam hayatımızın en
odağında bizleri gerçekten yetiştiren ve
asıl eğitimi veren kişiler onlar onlarla
Biz bir noktaya geliyoruz
hiç unutmuyorum İşte bizim zamanımızda
90'lık Uşak 90'da Eğitim gören kuşaklar
bilirler ÖSS üyesi varsa üniversite
sıralamamızı yapıyoruz abim oturduk Yoo
sıra Ben bir tek o diye biliyorum
tercihlerimizi yaptık yaptım Dershane
puanlarını genelde otobüs tatile giriyor
Benim puanım düşünüyorum ki ben herhalde
otobüs istatistik İstatistik ne yapar ne
eder iş var mıdır yok hiçbir şey
bilmiyorum sınav tarihleri ne yaptım hiç
unutmuyor Babam geldi olunca ne
yapıyorsun babacığım dedim sınav
tercihleri yapıyorum son tercih Gazi
hepsi öptü oğlum dedim geldi Buraya
Hacettepe istatistik Yazın ben dedim
başta bir ses dokuma Babam dedi bak Onun
dedim Baba sözü dinledi yazılım insan Bu
ancak sen diğer yerleri Kazan ne olur ne
olmaz dedi Sen bir baba sözü dedi Tamam
dedim
sınavda biraz sıkıntılar yaşadık
Herkesin başına gelen problemler saatini
yanlış kurmuşum vesaire vesaire bir
sınavdan çıktık aradan süre sınav sonuç
gazetesi Zaman gazetesi vardır gidersin
resmi Valisi alırsın sınav sonucuna
bakarsın baktım işte otobüs korunmasını
bakıyorum o tüm puantajlar yok Ben dedim
kazanamadım üniversiteyi dur abim geldi
Bir de ben bakayım dedim bak baktı
abicim dedi sen dedi kazanmışsın bakar
tabi istatistik dediğimiz anda evde
yangın çıktı o an evde yangın çıktı ve
kendimi Hacettepe istatistik ürünü
buldum hayatın odağına giren ve hayatına
şekil veren bu üniversiteyi girdim
Allah'a çok şükür
ama gerçekten çok önemli bir anda benim
için üniversiteye altın boyunca
istatisti anlamaya çalıştım istatistiğin
ne demek olduğunu nasıl oldu fakat bizim
zamanımızda istatistik uygulama imkanı
yok saman kağıtlarda sınavlar veriyoruz
bir sayfa ispatlar yapıyoruz biz bunu
nerede kullanacağız Biz Teknoloji yok
dost ekranları var çok az bilgisayar var
var orada bilgisayarlarında oyunlar
oynanıyor ancak
bilmiyoruz nerede kullanabiliriz yasağı
araştırma firmaları diyorlar ilk Siz et
bir tek üniversiteyi o dönemde biz Tansu
Çiller'in tam devalüasyonu denk gelen
bir uçak olduk ve o dönemde
arkadaşlarımın çoğu Ben dahil iş
bulmakta çok zorlandık Bu böyle
olmayacak ne yapmam lazım Ne yapmam
lazım dedim ki en iyisi dedim Master
yapayım bari Yapacak bir şey yok
hayatının Odak noktası orada başladı
kocalarından aldığım bilgiler sektörü
hızlı gelişimi konuşmamın başında
söyledi Ne dedin piramitin en
yukarısında olması mezunları Gün
geçtikçe ilerlemeye başladı ve Ne oldu
Ben aslında bilim öğrendikçe veri
öğrendikçe o verinin içerisindeki
hazine'nin ne demek olduğunu o
hazine'nin nelere sebebiyet verdiğini
görmeye başladım sonu Sn 15 Sn hele ki
bu işin tamamen tüm sektörler odağında
olduğunu gördüm Bizler biri Kopuyoruz
bir iyi koklayan adamlarız nasıl
meteorologlar havayı kokuyorlar havanın
nereye gideceğini sürüyorlar Biz
istatistikler ver neyin nasıl neden
niçin ve ne zaman yapacağımıza cevap
veren kişiler olduğumuzu fark ettim bu
fark etmenin ötesinde
Bu sektöre girdim sektöre girmemde ayrı
bir hikaye belki birkaç dedi konuşması
da bunu anlatmak gerekir Ama
işe girme anında Biz kaldım
ben karşımdaki insanı baktım o listesi
ciddi Tamam artık bir dedim 2tolga
Kaybedecek bir şeyin yok
kaynaklarını kazanman gerekiyor
Sen git iki faktör buldu üçüncü faktör
de işe girdim kişi patron ve çalışan
yoktu yanında birisi daha var o da
patron birbirinin misafir Gazi öbürü
onun personelimiz gibi davranıyor öbür
oğlum misafir geldim öbür onu
personelimiz abi dedim ki bu adam zeki
girdim Sebat ettim çalıştım kafa yordu
koşturdum zamanımı aradım emek verdim
Her şeyden önce inandım ve bunun
akabinde her şey kendiliğinden gelmeye
başladı bilgi ve birinin devamlılığını
kendi hayatında Ben görmeye başladım Biz
ise süsler birçok metot kullanıyoruz
regresyon modellemesi saman serilir
analizin Lojistik regresyon karar
ağaçları yapay sinir ağları Bu o kadar
fazla metodu var ki kaplamaya Survival
sağ kalıp analizi look analizi gibi
birtakım farklı metodları bu hayatta
kullanılabileceğini gördüm hayatta
kullanmak bu hayatta bildiğim bir şey
kullanmak
kullanabilmek o kadar büyük bir özgüven
veriyor ki insana Ha o kadar büyük bir
içerisinde olduğu gülsün ki Çünkü veri
ve bilgi
kazanılması gereken en önemli hazine
bunu alıyorsa bunun odağında olduğunu
hissediyorsun bu gerçekten hayat
anlamında benim için ve birçok
meslektaşım için ve bu konuda kendini
geliştirmek isteyen birçok insan için
önemli bir kazanım ve Tok önemli bir
katma değer
ama hepimiz bakıyoruz Şimdi O
bahsettiğim ağaç var o ağaç
bir karar ağacı olabilir bir karar
ağaçlarında O ağacın karar ağacın her
bir dalın size farklı olasılıklar
veriyor farklı seçenekler tanıyor seçim
şansı tanıyor size o seçeneklerden o
sesini seçtiğin zaman ne olacağı
hakkında Siz karar vermeniz destek
veriyor ve ben de bakıyorum ki bi öyle
dolduğunu önemsiyorum ki
ama biz hayatımızda doğru bir yolu
kullanmamız gerekiyor Bu doğru yolda
devam ederken
kararlarımızı bere biliyor olmamız
gerekiyor bilimsel Tabana dayalı olarak
Bu bir nevi baktığımız vakit bir ağaç
oluyoruz bir ağaç oluyoruz Bu bir karar
ağacı oluyor Biz bir karar ağacı
oluyoruz hayatımızda ve ellerimize
kozalakları mız var gözlerimizde
Kulaklarımız var ağızları mızda
Kulaklarımız var bu kozalaklar açılması
gerekiyor Bu bilginin atması gerekiyor
ve bu bilgilerle doğru kararları
hayatımızın odağını koyması gerekiyor
Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum beni
dinlediğiniz için
başarılar diliyorum
abone ol